this episode is brought to you by public
goods the one stop shop for sustainable
high quality everyday essentials made
from clean ingredients at an affordable
price i love these guys they have
everything from coffee to toilet paper
public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer and they have
everything from a to z people on my team
already used public goods before they
became a sponsor and i tested them and
now so do i one person loves their ramen
noodles for instance for backpacking
camping festivals like burning man and
so on another loves their bamboo
toothbrushes and now uses them and many
other products but uses them more than
his electric toothbrush i love their
candles and many of their food staples
my dog molly loves their freeze-dried
duck nibs the branding is simple
nice optimized for calm instead of flash
and public goods searches the globe to
find healthy eco-friendly and innovative
products and then packages them using a
single streamlined aesthetic for your
home so you can get all of your premium
essentials in one place affordably and
avoid buying from a bunch of mismatched
single product brands public goods also
ethically sources and obsessively
develops each of their products to be
free of unhealthy ingredients and
harmful additives still very common on
drug and grocery store shelves they use
a membership model to keep their costs
low and pass on even more savings to
their customers best of all you can now
make your first purchase with no
obligation and i'll get to that in a
second small changes in the way we shop
the way you shop the way i shop can make
a big impact on personal health and the
world at large so join hundreds of
thousands of others who have switched to
their new everything store public goods
i worked out an exclusive deal just for
you my listeners you can receive twenty
dollars off of the products in your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase so it's totally risk-free just
go to publicgoods.com tim or use code
tim that's tim at checkout one more time
that's p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com forward slash tim to receive
twenty dollars off of your first order
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
i have been using expressvpn all the
time constantly since the summer of 2019
and i find it to be a super reliable way
to make sure that my data are secure and
encrypted without slowing down
my internet speed whatsoever you don't
even notice that it's on it's one of the
best vpns on the market and it couldn't
be easier to set up their flow their
signup flow is actually incredible and i
encourage everyone just to check that
out all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would you click one
button in the expressvpn app to secure
100
of your network data one of the many
reasons
i use avpn is that free to access sites
all sorts of sites that you use every
day make their money by tracking your
searches or video history and
effectively everything you click on and
then they sell this valuable data onto
others when you use expressvpn you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your ip address that makes
your activity more difficult to trace
and sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your data to protect you
from hackers and assorted bad guys on
the internet so if you're on hotel wi-fi
or public wi-fi coffee shop wi-fi
whatever this is what i use
so it's finally time to take back your
online privacy at expressvpn.com
tim by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free again that's
expressvpn.com
tim one more time
expressvpn.com tim to protect your data
today
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hand starts
shaking can i ask you a personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
having a heap wave tropical heat
that's right
i think we might keep that in the intro
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of a very very warm tim ferriss
show i'll come back to that my guest
today is b jeffrey madoff m-a-d-o-f-f
jeffrey began his career in fashion
becoming one of the top 10 designers in
the u.s before switching careers to film
and video production he has directed
award-winning commercials documentaries
and web content for clients around the
world including ralph lauren victoria's
secret and tiffany
his book creative careers subtitled
making a living with your ideas is based
on the class of the same name he teaches
at parsons school of design jeff has
been a featured speaker at wharton
school princeton university nyu
steinhardt google next barclays rise and
verizon on the topics of creating a
brand and creativity he also works with
private equity firms and investment
banks such as lazard to create the brand
story for companies that are being sold
or for startups looking to attract
investment he graduated with honors from
the university of wisconsin with degrees
in philosophy and psychology we'll talk
about that he was also on the wrestling
team might sound familiar which combined
with his academic studies prepared him
for a life in the film business you can
find him online acreativecareer.com
madoffproductions.com and then on social
and instagram at a creative career as
well as at madoffproductions
and jeffrey jeff welcome to the show so
fun to see you fun to see you too thank
you for having me on and to paint a
picture i am
sweating profusely the ac has broken
in this home at an undisclosed location
and to hydrate because i have nothing
that is cold besides what is in my hand
i have
hard kombucha and jeff is drinking
carbonated water so this is an unfair
fight to begin with we'll see where this
all goes
and i thought we would start with
a i suppose the beginning of a story
that i cut short when we were having
lunch earlier today
and it came about because of the phrase
scratching your own itch or scratching
my own itch and you mentioned
ralph lauren which i confirmed is not
ralph lauren as many people say but
ralph lauren so i thought we would just
start there and if you could tell me the
story that i so rudely interrupted
earlier because i wanted to keep it for
the beginning of this show well i was
talking to ralph about how he got
started what motivated him to start a
business
and ralph's muse
were the movies he loved films and he
would really lose himself in the fantasy
of the movie house
and he'd look at people like carrie
grant and fred astaire and gary cooper
and
he wanted to dress like that and he
wanted to find suits that were cut like
that and ties that were wide like that
and they didn't exist and he started
designing first with ties then moved
into the rest of menswear and he started
designing that stuff because it was
stuff that he liked and he figured i'm
not the only one that wants to dress
like a movie star
and so i said to him you know you've
kept your
pulse on the consumer for so long
how have you done that for so many
decades i mean that's quite a feat and
he said
which is the kind of scratch your own
itch thing he said i know who my
consumer is
because i am the consumer
and so i thought that was just a really
brilliant insight not unlike when you
and i spoke when i interviewed you and
you talked about your book in the
four-hour work week you know it was the
same kind of thing you know for sure
yeah being and that was also i mean you
you have spent so much time in front of
students and speaking
[Music]
that
i know in some respects you know what
you've done in the classroom at parsons
school of design is is in some respects
scratching your own itch and that is
kind of doing what feeds and nourishes
you
or checks the box for an unmet need
and
i had
written this book because it was the
book i couldn't find and furthermore i
then had workshopped that although i
didn't know i was doing it at the time
by speaking to students and i knew what
students responded to and i knew what
fell flat and it was sort of like a
comic working on their one hour special
it's like you cut you were fine you test
again and that was the reason why after
26 29 however many rejections it was
i still kept going people sometimes ask
about how i maintained the faith and and
i i always point out it wasn't faith
like i already knew that at least there
was a verified market of one
which is ahead of a lot of folks so
let's
talk about
these degrees and philosophy and
psychology you've written in your book
that at the time when you graduated the
wisdom factories weren't hiring
so
what did you do after graduation
well i went to work in this boutique and
i'd actually been working there before
graduation and it was this little
clothing boutique in madison wisconsin
where i went to college
the
wall behind the cash register is where
we had the stereo system that puts it
into a time frame of many many years ago
and we were in the base of a rooming
house so when somebody od'd
and fell down the stairs the arm would
skip across the album
and we'd go up there goes a looming
house that's uh what is a rooming house
a rooming house is somewhere between an
apartment and a hotel
you know you pay every week you have a
room upstairs and
let's say that the clientele aren't
necessarily very upscale got it
in the campus where we were in downtown
this rooming house was kind of notorious
what was sold in the boutique we you
know we sold clothes
at the uh you know the old impulse buy
as they say or at a restaurant it might
be mints or when you're checking out at
the grocery store it's candy bars and
magazines
we had hash pipes and rolling papers
that was the impulse buy location
location location that's right
underneath the rooming house that's
right
and how did that job inform your path if
it did
well you know yes it did but i know how
it informed it in retrospect you know i
didn't realize that before
and that is my firm belief here's some
of the practical information i think
that everything you do if your eyes are
open informs everything else you do
and so
i didn't know anything about clothing
design and i was totally naive
i thought that when i saw fabric on the
bolt i thought that was wholesale
because it hadn't been made into
anything yet so
i was ignorant
fortunately not stupid uh
you know and the difference is
ignorant you can learn
stupids forever
[Laughter]
so you know i did i did learn and you
know and i wanted to go back and refer
to what you had mentioned in terms of
your book
because i think this is a really
important part and that is
you had at least 29 rejections i believe
it was like 34 before
it was a lot of rejections i was also
rejected from my first jobs
that was 30 30 plus rejections
quite a few so
you know so what's that component
that keeps
somebody going in the face of all those
rejections as opposed to
giving up you know and i think that
when i'm asked about entrepreneurship
and business and that sort of thing you
know what
what's a key ingredient and i'm curious
if you agree with this
i think it's perseverance
you know you mentioned
ignorant but not stupid i think i would
add to that informed perseverance
because i think that you can smash your
head against a wall and never break
through
but if you have
some
informational advantage
meaning in my case i had this feedback
from students i knew that the material
worked in front of live audiences
including people who would land squarely
in the demographic the book would be
positioned for
so i do think that's a huge component
you know if you have
informed belief
having the commitment to persevere
through the pain i think is a large
deciding factor and i should also just
add as color for this conversation
because people that most likely have no
idea we first met in 2007 or 2008
shortly after the first book had been
published you helped with the four-hour
body many many of the photographs
from the photo shoot and photo shoots
that we did
related to exercises
we're a product of your help we've
definitely
kind of been along jointly for each
other's rides over the last
it's hard to believe in a decade plus
now
and i love this type of conversation
with a friend because it gives me the
very
unnatural sort of asymmetrical
opportunity to just pepper you with all
sorts of questions that i get to
choose in a fairly lopsided way although
this can certainly be a conversation but
it also gives me an excuse to do a bunch
of homework on you which would otherwise
seem really creepy
so
let me ask you just as a way of looking
at your
earlier years
what or who are the hidden persuaders
my understanding this is a book that had
some effect on you the hidden persuaders
by vance packard
is that a fair statement yeah it is
interesting you bring that up going back
through the
memory bank here because i think i was
in seventh or eighth grade
and i read this book
and the hidden persuaders what it
related to is how products are placed
and what creates desire and this was
long before
behavioral economics was applied to
consumerism and that sort of thing
so to give a simple example
the colorful
cereal boxes
would be on the lower shelves so that
the kids would pull it off the shelf
and basically nag their parent
usually their mother at that point into
buying it
and so there were all these things i'd
never thought about strategic placement
of products or anything like that and
then i started realizing wow there's a
whole
science to this in terms of trying to
elicit preferences trying to place
things in the right eye line and the
fact that instead of being at five feet
which might be eye level for the mother
it's down at two feet where it's eye
level to the kid and so the kid will
take it off the shelf so packard's book
was like wow
i had never thought of that before and
it was really cool
how did you end up going from
fashion as a designer
where you found
quite a bit of success to film and video
production how and why
is this a mini series because this is
this is the beginning of our mini series
episode zero
i wanted to move to new york
and my financial backer was a very good
guy but he made it clear from the
beginning that he was
backing my company because
we banked at his bank and that
the employees of which i was 22 and i
had like 110 120 employees
i provided jobs for wisconsinites and we
banked at his bank
and
when i made the decision that i wanted
to move to new york
he said you know i'm not going to
continue to back you if you do you know
why i invested
and so i had to make a really big
decision at that point in my life which
is
you know i think 24
and do i
am i a failure if i close the business
you know what does this mean to me and
who i am you know i was
the type that went out there and
competed and did things and
now i would be closing down a business
that i had started
is that failure what is that
and i decided and i think part of this
is
uh influence of my dad
which is i learned that
money comes and goes
time only goes
and
that's a great way to put it and you
know
i mean i like the the way that words
relate you know like you can spend money
you spend time you waste money you waste
time investing in your future that's a
really weird concept when you think
about
what does that mean
and so
i decided
if anyone heard that that's molly trying
to eat flies that are deftly avoiding
her maw
please continue
you know i was so tempted to snap at
that one myself but i figured i didn't
want to interrupt the sound don't want
to throw your neck off that's right
so you know i made the decision to close
down the business and it was really
based on that kind of a conversation of
realizing
i could never replace the time but i
could replace the money quick
interruption was the desire to go to new
york to play in the big leagues
of design well i was already playing in
the big leagues and what made me unique
was i was doing that from wisconsin so
why go to new york and enter the shark
tank why go to new york because i
discovered i'm a stimulus junkie
i love the energy of new york the
activity you know if you're bored in new
york it's on you
right there is so much going on all the
time and
i can go hear a jazz concert see a play
eat at a great restaurant and walk to
all those places i love it that's why
you know flying saucers land in wyoming
and new york you can't find a place to
park
so
i
was seduced by the energy of new york
and wanted to be there
and one of the people i did uh bought
fabrics from
he said to me
do you know anything about the movie
business
and i said not really i mean i've read
some books i love film but not really
and he said well my son is your age
and you're a bright kid you have a good
head on your shoulders would you mind
meeting him because he's getting
involved with some people
and he's not going to listen to me but
maybe he'll listen to you would you mind
meeting with him he's your age
no i don't mind at all happy to well the
people he was involved with was dennis
hopper
william burroughs
and terry southern
and
tommy
the son had bought the rights to junkie
which was one of william burroughs
novels and dennis hopper was going to
direct it
and star in it
and
so this was
interesting you know i mean you've got
dennis hopper coming off of easy rider
and then apocalypse now yeah you gotta i
think for people who are listening who
maybe don't recognize the name or the
gravitas at that time associated with
that ham i mean that's a big deal
it was a very big deal and he had just
come off of filming apocalypse now with
marlon brando another iconic film name
and
dennis would get the checks from
zoetrope which was francis ford
coppola's film studio
endorse it on the back then give it to
burroughs assistant
and he would go out and score drugs and
buy alcohol
the shortest line between two points
that is correct that's correct so i
thought wow zolotroke that's copolis
studio oh there it goes
so
and when i met dennis we really hit it
off and it was kind of a weird way that
we hit it off i've never shared this
before but it's funny i think you get a
kick out of it
i said you know why i i'm familiar with
you dennis he goes yeah man i know
easy rider
and i said actually it's not easy ryder
said what i said now i remember all
those warner brothers tv westerns and
everybody would be wearing hollywood
wardrobe of what a cowboy looked like
but you actually had the 10 gallon hat
and actual authentic cowboy clothing
because man you're blowing my mind man
nobody ever said that man you know what
i would do man i would take my own money
and i would go to arizona i'd go to
texas and i would buy authentic actual
western clothes man nobody's ever said
that that was my money man so he loved
me after that did i know that was where
the fashion background kicked in yeah no
kidding so it was really funny so i
was granted a part in this movie
acting role an acting role he wanted me
to act in it which i thought would be a
blast
although it became clear
that this was never going to get made
because these guys were staying at the
chelsea hotel which was another awesome
destination in new york
and
they would
get up at about five in the afternoon
have something to eat then start
drinking
doing blow
and by about two in the morning it had
devolved
into dennis and uh terry southern
arguing who actually wrote easywriter
that had the same argument it was like
it was like groundhog day the loop would
start yes yes it was like an escher
drawing you know
and uh so they would argue with each
other really animated arguments you
thought they were going to get into a
fight which they never did
fear and loathing in new york city and
the funny thing was is that burroughs
would sit there and he would click off
his hearing aid
because he didn't want to listen to any
of this stuff so he'd click off his
hearing aid they'd argue and then they'd
fall asleep
and then i'd get there the next day at
around five see the mirror with all the
finger scrapings on it from the blow
and i said to tommy
they're going to squeeze you out of this
and this movie's never going to get made
what do you mean it's my film and i said
these guys can't get it together to go
have dinner
you know
you think that they're actually going to
get a movie made not going to happen
yeah
sure enough about two weeks later they
offered him money to buy his part out
and
so you were nostradamus i was
nostradamus or just somebody who
realized these guys can't get out of
their own way it's not happening
so they offered him four times as much
money as they paid for it
and
i said take it
how long have you held the rights he
said four months so you've quadrupled
your money in four months
and this film's never going to get made
take the money and run
so the reason tim that you've never seen
me on the big screen
is because the film never got made
but at least he got his money out of it
and how did you
go from that
into being involved in production
god it's so convoluted how things happen
but there was a lawyer who was
representing
william burroughs
and he thought i was an interesting guy
we're around the same age he was at
young
and he wanted to introduce me to some
people
and what i had seen that was really
attractive to me is
the promise of what it could be to make
a film and tell a story like that that
was really exciting to me
so i met these people that were starting
a company a production company and they
asked me to join him and i did
and taught myself how to shoot how to
edit how to light how to do all that
stuff two questions why did the lawyer
do that presumably he's got many things
he could spend his time on
so why do you think he
offered to make introductions and then
number two without any previous
production experience
why did that production company want to
bring you on
they wanted to specialize in fashion
uh and so my knowledge of fashion had
value to them
and when we first started watching some
of the videos they had done together i
was able to distinguish between like
when i saw work i really liked i said
who's that cinematographer and then
we'd watch for another hour and then
something come up and say that's the
same cinematographer isn't it i said
yeah how did you know like i could
recognize style and recognize you know
how it was done and so they were
interested in my fashion knowledge that
was one thing
and i
kind of had
for whatever reason an innate and i can
tell you the reason actually an innate
understanding
of the medium
so
earlier i mentioned i think everything
you do informs everything else you do
when i was designing clothes it would
start with a sketch
i'd have to cost out what were the
materials what was the labor how long
would it take to get made
could i ship it by a deadline collect
the money for it and start the cycle
over again well making a film you start
off with storyboards you know a concept
you figure out the costs of the labor
involved the cost of the materials and
rentals involved and can you complete it
by this time and deliver on deadline i
would imagine that there's the
process similarity but that also
whether it's by nature or
nurture i don't know but your ability to
look at
fashion and the components of fashion
visually in high definition
had to also be
reflected in your ability to spot the
same cinematographers right a certain
visual acuity i would imagine
also helped yeah i mean that that helped
and that was certainly developed
as i was doing the fashion work
that's a part of what i do is you know
dealing in those visuals so yeah you're
right and
i think that you know
jargon is what separates a lot of fields
as opposed to if you look at just the
protocol and the practice
most businesses are the same in those
very broad strokes they're very much the
same yeah the vernacular the terminology
is different that's right different
dialects of the same language that's
right and the lawyer why did he help you
so the lawyer helped because
he was more
more than a lawyer
he was a deal maker yeah that's a great
point and so he was really interested in
bringing me into this mix to show them
he knew people
and that's really why he brought me and
he said you know this guy's got the
fashion knowledge you need
he's working on this film he has a sense
of what production is you guys ought to
meet
and so that was why because that was
part of his
selling point was that he knew people
yeah which i should point out is i think
one of the things that
separates in some cases really good
lawyers from great lawyers is that they
are deal makers and they're very
creative about getting deals done
and they recognize that by getting deals
done
they ultimately have the most renewable
resource of repeat clientele they could
ever want
but there are very technically
legally adroit lawyers who
are perhaps more interested in billable
hours and the kind of micro level
tactics but they're not deal makers at
heart and they're very different animals
really different so i'm glad you
mentioned that i'm going to grab another
hard kombucha and be right back i'm
going to ask you about
success and definitions thereof with
your students well i just want to
mention one make a comment about your
lawyer thing and that is
in that definition of good lawyers who
can recognize a potential deal and do
something they're also kind of like if
they were a doctor they would infect you
so they could treat you
because they
they create more work for themselves by
putting those deals together i mean i
guess there are sort of uh not to use
like dungeons and dragons parlance but
they're
like constitutionally there are sort of
uh
there are the light arts for doing that
and then there are the dark arts
[Laughter]
and they're different they're very
different so let's talk about students
at the beginning of every semester at
parsons you ask your students to define
success or at least you've done that
many times
why do you do that
and you can answer this in whatever
order you'd like and what have been some
of the insights or answers
that stick out
or what are you looking for let's just
explore why you do that because you
mentioned when you had to or chose to
lay off whatever was 110 120 people
in wisconsin you were asking yourself is
this failure does this mean i'm a
failure like what does this mean right
and we're meaning making machines as
humans so you ask students to define
success
why
i think it's really important to
question some fundamentals that maybe
you never asked yourself
so what does success look like
i think is a really important question
and it doesn't mean by the way that your
definition
can't change i mean my
personal definition has changed
but i think it's always important to
sort of have your own compass going on
and knowing what it is you're after what
it is that you're you're doing and so
some will say well you know having
enough money and oftentimes money is
attached to this having enough money so
that i don't have to worry about
anything
and i said so having enough money so
you're not worried about anything
can you
be making that much money
however
also hate doing what you're doing every
day you're doing it would you still
consider yourself successful
and so that starts a dialogue so i use
that as kind of a kindling
in the hopes of igniting a dialogue
about thinking about what does success
really mean
and
one of the things that i think is
overlooked in so many circumstances is
context
and looking at that in context and
looking about you know what success is i
mean the nature of success to me changed
when i got married
when i had kids
and then i thought of a separate
definition of success
when my business was going really well
and that was
i'd consider myself successful when i
could say no without any negative
financial consequences so the freedom
to say no was a big part of success for
me
but
now i'm in a different stage of life and
i would say that my definition of
success has evolved for me
into
engagement
i want to be engaged in what i'm doing i
want to be excited about doing it i want
to look forward to it and i don't care
how much money
i be getting if i'm not engaged if i'm
not involved i don't want to spend my
time doing that
what does engagement feel like like how
how would you know you're engaged you
know you're engaged when
you are unaware of the time that passes
that
you are so in the zone of the work that
you're doing
that
time doesn't mean anything and you love
doing it
and that you look forward to the next
time you get to do it
and that can also mean the group of
people that you're collaborating with
and working with that you just enjoy
that process
and
to me that's what's really important is
you know knowing and understanding why i
want to do this
and
that it brings me fulfillment
and i think that's really important
how do you choose who you interview for
your class i mean you've interviewed
some enormous names taylor swift being
just one example
how do you choose them what are the
criteria or what are you looking for
what are you hoping to share with your
students how do you go about guest
selection now this is interesting
because is this also scratching your own
itch
okay tell me more
you know and by the way taylor swift was
as part of a victoria's secret job she
didn't do my class just to be clear
nonetheless
you know i i think that i didn't want
our legal department contacted me
fair enough she never did that he was
misrepresenting uh
so
my criteria for a guest is is
they demonstrated in some way whether
it's a lecture i heard a their book that
i read an article whatever
that they've got
knowledge
that i think is
interesting
compelling can bring about a change in
the way people look at things make
people aware of things
so it's really you know scratching my
own itch i find what they're doing
really interesting and i love the idea
of being able to talk to somebody
and explore what they do and learn from
what they do teaching is a fabulous way
to learn yeah it really is and i love
learning
so side note for people i don't know if
this footage can even be found anywhere
but
thanks to your introductions you may
remember
if people could find this it would be
hilarious
there was a very
unusual promo that i did for the
four-hour chef during one of the
victoria's secret annual events
and i ended up cooking some dish and i
think it was alessandra ambrosio or
ambrosia
and then adriana lima
next to me and i have never felt like
such a
hobbit slash bridge troll i mean the the
visual was so hilarious because
a they're super tall and obviously
stunningly gorgeous and they're in heels
and there i am like three feet shorter
with some kind of willy wonka jacket on
trying to make god knows what it's quite
hilarious so if people can find that i
highly recommend taking a look at it
finding people who are interesting i
want to shift to someone who may or may
not be interesting and we're going to
we're going to move from new york city
to the mojave desert
can you please tell the story of the
life coach who lived deep in the mojave
desert
i'm laughing because i i
love that you picked that
[Laughter]
and i don't know the story i do i do not
know the story i'm just using the prompt
because i want to hear you tell the
story
uh i may have to reread my book
so there was this person that i heard
about
who supposedly had
insights into what makes life meaningful
and eternal
and how old were you at the time
and i was in my
late 20s early 30s okay
you know the seeking ages
and
i heard about this person who lived deep
in the mojave desert
and that for a fee
for a fee you know he would share that
knowledge
and so
it was really hard to get there by the
way it's not like there were direct
flights to this place or anything
and so i make this journey which
involved
plane flight
then a train
then walking
and you know a car and it was like quite
a thing to get to this isolated place
and
i go in and there's this kind of very
beautiful man
smooth skin you know like porcelain and
he's sitting you know cross-legged on
the floor and he uh
motions me in
and
asks me to sit down i sit down and
he said you were a seeker
i'm thinking well
yeah i made it here
seeking something that's not under the
umbrella of big insight
and he said you see this fire
yes
he said first i want you to close your
eyes
and i closed my eyes
and he said you know i'm closing my eyes
and he said you've opened your eyes and
i'm thinking how did you see that your
eyes are shined i was testing you you
know what's going on here
she said close your eyes and i want you
to allow your mind to go blank
and i want you to think of nothingness
so
i won't tell you where my mind went but
it didn't go to nothingness and
and
he said now i want you to open your hand
and place it in front of you and i
opened my hand a place in front of me
and he said your right hand and i'm
thinking again how did he know
his eyes are closed
and he said put your palm towards the
ground and move it in front of you and
that's where the fire was so i move in
front he says now i want you to
slowly put your hand into the fire
okay
and i opened my eyes and said are you
[ __ ] crazy i'm not putting my hand in
the fire
and he said you know how many people i
have to stop once they start putting
their hand down i reach out we're in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere
if they burn their hand seriously i'm in
the [ __ ] and they're feeling miserable
and we're probably 120 miles from any
kind of hospital
so thank goodness you had the good sense
not to do that
you want a beer
and so he hands me a beer and he's got
this diamond encrusted
can opener
and he said yeah one of my followers
sent me this you believe this they spent
their money on a [ __ ] diamond
beer can opener
so he takes a big sip of it
and i do and he said to me
you came here for the secret right and i
said yes
he said okay here's the big secret i
said what's that he said there is no
secret
if you were to put half of the effort
into your own career and what you're
doing into what it took you to get here
you'd have been far ahead of the game
everybody comes here thinking that i've
got some secret and they're so invested
in all the
what it takes to get here
that i feel like i have to do something
and i said what about the eternal life
thing he said listen you live in the
middle of nowhere with a bunch of people
coming up wanting a piece of you and all
the answers from you
it feels like an eternity
and i said why do you do it he goes yeah
it's a living
that's amazing
okay
with a few follow-ups
how did you hear about this guy
and
what impact did that have if any on you
okay here's the big reveal tim
you are the man sitting cross-legged
and simultaneously across from myself
yeah uh
the big reveal is that
i wanted to end my book with a parable
and so i made that story up ah
and i like it i can't tell you how many
people said well who is this guy
and all of that kind of thing and what
inspired me to write it is that there
are so many
self-acclaimed people with insight
and so many people who are clamoring
to share in that insight so it'll
somehow unlock the secrets of riches
and long life to them
and i thought
you know what it really takes and i
don't know any exceptions to this rule
unless you're born into money
is it takes a [ __ ] load of work that's
what it takes to do
what i've done what you've done what
everybody i know who has accomplished
something has done
so there are no secrets
what there is is the hard work the
perseverance
and you know that
keeps you going after what you're going
for there aren't any secrets to unlock
you got to do the work
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs it's summer of 2021 and
with all the rapid changes we've seen
since last year small business owners
are busier than ever time spent
searching for and interviewing the wrong
candidates for job opening could be time
better spent growing a business growing
your business that's why linkedin jobs
has made it even easier and faster to
reach candidates worth interviewing
create a job post for free in minutes on
linkedin jobs to reach your network and
well beyond to the world's largest
professional network of more than 750
million people that's a lot of people
focus on candidates with the skills and
experience you need use screening
questions to get your role in front of
only the most qualified people then use
the simple tools on linkedin jobs to
quickly filter and prioritize who you'd
like to interview and then hire linkedin
jobs helps you find the candidates worth
interviewing faster did you know that
every week nearly 40 million job seekers
visit linkedin
post your job for free at linkedin.com
tim that's linkedin.com tim to post your
job for free terms and conditions
apply want to talk about a particular
type of work
quote i was hired to sell shoes not be a
zookeeper
please elaborate
those don't go together
so
when i was a kid i was about 16 and a
new shopping mall was opening in akron
ohio which is where i grew up
i'm going to piggyback the story
piggyback the monkey story
yeah
i feel like dr doolittle right now
[Laughter]
uh
there was a manager there and it was a
chain of stores
they had run an ad for somebody who was
at least 23 i had shoe selling
experience and was married i was 16
unmarried and never sold a shoe
so why let that stop you well that was
my thought yeah you know truly and so i
met with this guy and you know i had
done door-to-door sales i'd done all
kinds of selling what did you sell dirty
door not to digress
i was a fuller brush man which maybe
many of your listeners don't even know
what that is i don't know what that is
paint brushes no fuller brush was like
kitchen stuff and personal grooming
stuff
and went around with a sample case
you'd start off so they wouldn't slam
the door in your face you'd say i've got
a free gift for you that was a big thing
back then
you know and it's like being a
missionary yes and you get you get a
choice of one of three gifts that we've
got this week
and then you try to sell them you know
shampoo or dish soap or whatever one
time a woman
opens the door wearing a robe
and her
hair is wrapped up in a towel and i said
in our special this weekend it may
interest you since you just got out of
the shower is our hairspray
and she said well you know i actually
could use the hairspray now
can i you have a sample and i said yeah
and so i pick up the aerosol everything
was aerosol back then yeah and i handed
the aerosol can and she starts to she
first brushes her hair then she sprays
this
and as she's spraying and i see oh man
i handed her the oven spray
[Laughter]
so i take the can back before she like
looks at it and puts it back into things
she's going
this was very firm
and i'm thinking yeah and food won't
stick to your head either
she actually bought it she was probably
probably disappointed you know with the
actual hairspray
but you know i had
30 seconds
yeah to engage a potential customer
before they closed the door in my face
yeah i mean nowadays i don't even think
you get anybody to open the door but
back then you could so it was an
actually amazingly good experience for
selling and that also prepped me for
retail when somebody walks into the
store how do i engage them and get them
selling
so i had that conversation with bob who
was the manager and he said look i can't
hire you
you know you're supposed to be 23 or 16.
you're supposed to be married you're
single i just love that the number is
23. yeah
and uh
he went on to found 23 and me i'll just
just kidding so anyhow
i said i can't hire you i'm really sorry
i like you but
i can't hire you and i said
well i sold you
and you've got a it's got to be harder
to sell you than a pair of shoes
and he lance said i'm sorry
so as i'm walking out he comes after me
and he said
all right [ __ ] it you're hired
and he hired me
i said why are you hiring me and he said
well you're right you sold me i'm
willing to take a chance on you
well that was really good management
because although he had policies
when he saw what he thought would be a
good opportunity and i in fact i was a
very successful salesman for them he was
willing to take a chance take a risk and
do something and sort of
make the perimeter for the job
qualifications a bit more elastic to fit
me in well in the back of the store
there was a monkey
in the back of the shoe store in the
back of the shoe store
uh there
was a monkey
and
attention do i have your attention
interested interest are you interested
yes
decision have you made your decision for
christ
yeah anyway for those who don't get the
reference you can look it up
and uh as you had said earlier this is
an adult show yeah exactly so
the idea behind having a monkey in the
back of the store which by the way would
never ever happen these days not up to
good no no uh so the you know since it
was a family shoe store the mother would
come in then she'd say to the kids
go back and look at the monkey
what could go wrong by the way a phrase
that i had never heard before or since
go back and look at the monkey
and so there was a when we first opened
there was a name the monkey contest okay
and the monkey's name the winning name
was solo
now at that time the man from uncle
was the most popular tv show and the
hero's name was napoleon solo that's why
everybody thinks we chose the name solo
the truth revealed here for the first
time
is we named it solo because all the
monkey did was masturbate
and so
of course what would you do city yeah
and so
the mother would then look back to look
at her kids and she'd see the
monkey furiously masturbating get away
from the cage get away from you
so somebody had to clean the cage
finally getting to your point and the
assistant manager you know masturbating
makes that task so much worse i didn't i
didn't know that detail
i didn't want to reveal everything over
lunch
[Laughter]
and so the manager jimmy says to me the
assistant manager
wants you to clean out the monkey cage
and there were five other employees and
i was by far
the youngest
and
i said do you ever clean out the monkey
cage
and he said i told you to clean out the
monkey cage
and i said and by this time the other
employees gathered around because he was
very animated when he said that
and i said to him i'll take my turn
if everybody else takes their turn
otherwise i was hired to sell shoes not
be a zookeeper
he must love that he said i told you to
clean out that cage
and then bob the manager who hired me
had heard this and walks over
and he says jimmy
why don't you show them how to clean the
cage properly
and then you'll take your turn jeff will
take his and then everybody else will
take theirs
well i was okay with that because then
everybody was treated equally and fairly
and i wasn't treated differently
because i was a kid
and i was often the top selling sales
person
so
again i learned something about
management
from that which is first of all
hear people
listen and hear people don't just assume
because the assistant manager said i'm
not doing something there maybe there's
a reason maybe there's something to
learn from that maybe there's something
to make the situation better for the
employees or whatever
and again he demonstrated this very
common sense good judgment and that
stayed with me to this point traumatized
by the masturbating monkey by learning
learning from his management prowess
which i thought was quite good
oh my god masturbating monkeys
glenn gary glenross alec baldwin's
performance is my reference from earlier
for people who've missed it good
reference by the way thank you thank you
and the last is action
a-i-d-a flipped over on the chalkboard
i think he was nominated for an oscar he
was that like six minute performance uh
which is just incredible david mamet
wrote it
such an incredible writer i mean just
stunning stunning writer
this is a complete non-sequitur but i
have to ask and and and we're jumping
around but that's the nature of our
conversation the monkey by the way
the monkey
sir from monkey masturbation to 2009
so you are
mad off
as you
uh reminded me
very kindly before we started so i was
asking you about lauren versus lauren
now there is a madoff
who became quite famous in the wider
world
so i don't know if this is accurate were
you actually quoted in the new york
times as saying i got a package at my
office which i returned to the post
office because it was addressed to burn
bernard madoff with no return address is
that you being quoted or is that
somebody else yeah it is so
what was that
what was did that year turn into a
massive headache for you or was it
really just a comical distraction for a
short period of time
it's interesting it was a few things so
first of all my first initial although i
go by my middle name jeffrey my first
initial is b
right for ben
and uh not benjamin not benjamin and not
big
well let me say that let me phrase that
differently but anyhow
yes has ben
and
i would get calls all the time my office
would get calls because it was madoff
productions the mnemonic so you can keep
it clear in your own mind is he made off
with the money
i'm mad off
so we got this package
and the package was
addressed like a kidnap note you know
there were
letters
cut out of a magazine or magazines that
sounds promising yeah and i thought i
doubt if this is anything good
you know
but i didn't know
it was even potentially dangerous oh it
could be a bomb and i had gotten so many
calls
at all hours of the day and night four
in the morning i would get calls
from people who had lost their money
enough yes and i you know i had
real compassion for these people because
in good faith these people invested
and
they had lost their money
and so i got
some really horrible
calls some people who were crying and
begging and i said
it's not me and bernard has been
sentenced do you think that you're going
to find a number in the phone book there
are still phone books then i'm not him
and yeah i got a call at five in the
morning from fox and friends
it rang i pick up the phone and they say
you know i forget the person's name from
fox and friends we'd love to have you on
today you know bernard madoff is being
sentenced and we'd love to have you on i
said well first of all let me be clear
at five in the morning
uh you were not my friend
and no i had no interest on being on
your show
and
i said well we we know it's early but we
wanted to get to you today and i said do
you think that i want your audience to
see me on the screen then you talk about
madoff or madoff being
sentenced with my face on there and
they're gonna think it's me
i want absolutely no part of this
nothing but upset yeah that's right
that's right exactly
sounds like a wonderful opportunity you
know uh
could you put a target on me too uh and
you know uh tiffany anthrax i can borrow
and i was aggressively pursued for the
david letterman show
they wanted me just because you had a
name that was spelled the same way yeah
so they wanted to do top 10 reasons
for not having the last name
and so they called me a few times and it
happened my studio was
less than a block away from letterman's
studio and so as producers invited me
over trying to talk me into it
and i said look i understand that you
guys have to entertain your audience
every night five nights a week
and i'm not interested in making fun or
making light of the pain that so many
people have suffered nor am i interested
in being the butt
of jokes because my last name is spelled
the same way said well do you know how
big our audience is
do you know how huge an ass you could
appear yeah it's two hours there's so
many of our national audiences yes
yeah i said i'm aware you know uh no
and uh
you know but what ended up happening so
there was there was a period of time
and obviously to this day i'm still
asked about it when my mom died
and this was in 2010 i'm in akron with
my wife we're at the funeral home
and the funeral director
is looking at the certificate and he
says to me i couldn't help but to notice
the last name
i said what you usually don't check when
you're going to bury somebody
and he said well i do see the last name
may i ask are you related
and i said yes it's my mother
so that ended that discussion
but what i did though was i wrote an
article
i get a call back from the daily beast
and i hadn't submitted it i sent it out
to a bunch of friends and somebody must
have submitted it
it was called i'm not that mad off
and
or i'm not that made of yeah right
correct
and uh you know i've never gone into
this so this is kind of bringing back
memories not all of them good and so the
daily be said this is what you got we
love your article i said thank you we'd
like to publish it thank you but we want
you to make one change i said and what's
that
well
you have a line in there it's very funny
it's very clever but you have this line
in there that we'd like you to take out
and i said what's that and they said you
say that
wealthy people often cloak themselves in
religious and philanthropic causes to
inoculate themselves against criticism
and i said yeah
so we'd like you to take that out i said
no
and they said well i mean we'd love to
run it but we would like to take that
out and i said how much you paying me
for this
zero but i wouldn't take it out anyhow
and i said no that's integral to the
piece why did they want you to take that
out that's as far as i'm concerned it's
the statement of fact it is
i mean you don't have to look very far
to get a lot of confirming evidence
why did did they give you a reason
no other than you know they thought that
it was very clever and good but they
didn't like that part because it got
serious
so i said no the next day i got a call
from the huffington post
love your articles thank you
we'd love to run it i said as is they
said we wouldn't change it absolutely
and then that led to me writing for them
so i did around 50 some articles because
i wanted
to get down the discipline of writing
regularly so they didn't impose that on
me but i did an article a week for them
for a little better than a year
and so it actually ended up being
something good
so i don't know if this is going to be a
natural segue or not like all of our
others monkey mastery
yeah all of my monkey masturbating to
glengarry glenn ross segways
i'm a natural folks
just
just goes to show how far you can get
with perseverance and a lot of ignorance
but that's how you know since we've
known each other the conversations are
like pinball they're always like this
they're always like this yeah pinball
meets racquetball
meets lsd uh lloyd price
who is lloyd price
well lloyd price
is a dear friend who died on may 4th
and lloyd price is and i hate this term
because it's beaten to death but it's
true in his case an icon one of the
founding fathers of rock and roll
he's in the rock and roll hall of fame
and his first song
lottie miss clawdy back in 1952
broke down the wall that was called race
records where you could only buy records
by black artists in black record stores
and
lottie miss claudia sold
and was the first record to sell this
much over a million copies no record by
a young person had ever sold anywhere
near that yeah that's crazy i mean it's
a crazy yeah and by the way at that time
which would have been my grandparents
generation
kids didn't buy records
the only kid records were shirley temple
you know kids did not buy records it
wasn't a market so there were a bunch of
independent labels around the country
that sold blues gospel and jazz
and this was the breakthrough album so
there are many
rock and roll and musical scholars
consider it the cornerstone song of rock
and roll
and it was covered by elvis by the
beatles by bruce springsteen on and on
and on
and i
met lloyd we really hit it off and i was
where was that i met him in like
2012 or 13 something like that
and i was asked to do a documentary
about him because they wanted to start
getting his story out there in hopes of
doing something
and so i researched him and
i met him first really liked him and
then researched him and did this
documentary
and i was so
taken by his story because it takes
place at the crossroads of the youth
movement
the birth of rock and roll and the civil
rights movement
and
i felt like this is a story that needed
to be told most people don't know
lloyd's story and just how influential
he was
and in breaking down that wall that was
called race records nobody's prejudiced
against green
you know
and so that's very true and he opened
the doors not only for black musicians
but for young musicians and that started
that tidal wave that became rock and
roll
so
he and i became very close friends and i
said to him after doing the documentary
i know i can capture your voice i want
to tell your story
little did i know
that meeting him was going to be a
life-changing
event
because since then i wrote the first few
scenes read them for lloyd so let's
pause here for a second so you wrote the
first few scenes of what of a play yeah
here we go yeah i wrote the first few
scenes how did you get to a play did you
already have it in your mind when you
said i can capture your voice was it in
the form of a play yes and although
movie was in the back of my mind as a
next step but play
there's something about
theater
in live performances whether you're
seeing a play whether you're seeing a
comedian
even a live concert where
the talent
is at risk the entire time they're in
front of an audience
because in movies you can do another
take yeah
on a play you can't
yeah i love that you know and so that
risk i find profound and profoundly
seductive because you have to be there
present in the zone to really be good at
what you're doing and i have so much
respect for the talent that i work with
and the actors that i work with it's
incredible
and comedians
they put a product out there
and they get immediate feedback you know
it's no a b testing right you know they
they laugh or they don't that's right
there's no charity that's not funny they
don't laugh that's right
yeah and you can't talk them into
you know that was funny yeah
that's right that's the proof and so
you've got to pivot
quick
and recover quick
and if you get angry at your audience
for not doing it that's the death knell
of your career
i stopped you when you said i wrote the
first few scenes i don't know if you
remember that thread to pick up on that
wasn't sure where the thought was going
you wrote the first few scenes
of i'm not sure if it was called this
the time but personality subtitle the
lloyd price musical
uh based on his life
um and what happened when you wrote the
first few scenes well i wrote the first
few to tell him the kind of voice i
wanted to do the play in right so
when i read them out loud to him he
loved it
and i said to him he said you've got it
and i said to him but there's something
really important that we need to
understand
right now and he said what's that
and i said you're the messenger
this story is bigger than you
because
your life and what you did
change the face of music
created was instrumental in creating
this new form
and you're the messenger
and he said jeff i've been waiting years
for somebody to say that to me and
they're all puff smoke up my ass and
it's not about my ego it's about wanting
to tell this story
that's why i want you to do it
and that began a friendship and a
collaboration
that
lasted
until his death and now i have an
additional
mission and purpose which is to keep his
legacy and story and music alive
so many questions i want to ask you
first how did it feel
what was it like to hear him say that to
you i've been waiting
to have somebody say that
it was really gratifying
what i said could have pissed him off if
he was a lesser person
but his ego didn't get in the way of
that and lloyd had a phrase
the truth needs no defense oh that's
great and i love yeah i love that
i love that and you know he had another
one which i thought about as i was
raising money for this
which is i was telling him about some of
the meetings and someone who said jeff
you got to understand something
there's
a million ways to say no
there's only one way to say yes you
write a check
right we'll get back to you let us think
on it yeah
and there are people by the way that
just love having meetings
and they think it's cool to have a
meeting about a play and all of that
kind of thing yeah if you want to all
you can eat buffet of that just spend a
bunch of time in los angeles you'll get
plenty of practice
[ __ ] meetings and phone calls jeez
louise
so
as it stands right now
where is
this musical
the state of affairs so the state of
affairs is back in september of 20. we
had a thing we got a theater deal we did
a workshop
first of all let me say that if i knew
how long it took to mount to play i
would have started when i was younger
and
we did a full-up workshop with
choreography in the end of march 2019.
we got a theater deal
and that theater deals with people's
light theater in malvern a very good
regional theater
and we're very excited about that and
that's in pennsylvania yes and we were
we were
going to
open
in march of 21.
with kovid
i had to make the decision
because theaters by the way get booked
up a year and a half to two years in
advance
so in september of 20 i made the
decision to see if we could move it if
my management could move it to
2022 which is what we did i was
prescient of you
would have been really screwed if i was
wrong yeah fortunately or not
fortunately i wish covid was over yeah
but my hope is that by march we'll not
only all be safe we will believe that
we're safe
and that people will be attending
theater which is you know beginning to
happen bruce springsteen opened his show
on broadway last weekend i mean today's
june 30th that we're doing this
it is june 30th and last saturday i'm
just putting a time frame on this
uh springsteen was the first broadway
show to open and he sold out wow and
three weeks before that the colbert show
invited full audience without face masks
they just had to pass a covet test and
show proof of vaccination and he's been
full to capacity every day since those
are all good omens so that's really good
yeah the roaring 20s here we go so we're
now in the process i am raising some
more money because that's you know it's
like any startups like the tech startups
you've been with you know you cross a
certain threshold then you've got to
raise money for the next stage and then
you cross that stage and you got to
raise money for the next stage
we've got
wonderful talent involved sheldon epps
who's the director is phenomenal who's
been with me since the beginning as has
shelton becton who is the
musical director
and chester gregory who plays lloyd
and stanley mathis who plays logan who
was lloyd's mobster
mentor and many many awards yeah i mean
just these people yeah we have
creative team
david gallo who's won multiple tony
awards is doing set in projection
and rob kaplowitz
who was doing sound design as a tony
award winner and
we just have a tremendous number of
people involved who are so good and so
committed to the project
that's very gratifying and you might
like this when i hired sheldon which was
before we did our first reading
and i really liked him and i liked his
insights into theater and everything
else and
so i said to him
i want you to know i have a no [ __ ]
rule
and he laughed he says well i think i
know what you mean why don't you explain
it to me and i said
if you are an [ __ ] but you are paying
me
i'll put up with it but i will never put
up with abuse
but if you're an [ __ ] and i'm paying
you
i won't put up with it
and he laughed and said we're in the
same place and we have built such a
sense of community for each of the
productions we've done and it's been
just a joy
and the thing is and i said this to the
assembled cast before we did our
workshop
is
and i think this is a general life
lesson for me anyhow which is never let
anybody rob the joy of the process
because the process is what's magic
the process is what's so much fun
and that's the journey on your way to
that finished product that process i
mean that's where the real stories come
in
as you're on that journey and uh it's
also the bulk of your time that's right
that's right because once it's up and on
its feet
there's a lot less to do
is it fair to say that and i know very
little about theater but that the
people's light theater in malvern and
certainly others sort of around the
epicenter of broadway
act as effectively feeders if they're
successful into broadway
yes yeah it is and that's from whether
it's la jolla play house
in california or whether it's goodman
theater
in washington
you know there are many
regional theaters a very high order you
know the public theater in new york is a
regional theater that's where hamilton
started la jolla playing this is where
jersey boys started kidding and those
were all like what we have enhancement
deals but the big caveat is if you're
successful right could you define for
people who don't know the term
enhancement deal an enhancement deal
basically means that a theater
a good regional theater will set aside a
certain amount of money for original
productions maybe they do one or two or
tops three a season
so they have their fixed budget
and then on our end we have to enhance
that budget with the rest of the
financial contribution
so
they're putting up the set shop they're
building the sets
they're building the costumes they're
doing the marketing and sales they're
doing all of those things and if there's
is any recruitment they'll be able to
get that so we're not producing it
but what we are doing is marketing from
that you know that's the idea but we've
enhanced their budget so we're both able
to put on a play
that
the cost would be prohibitive for either
party alone but together in pooling
resources we're able to do the
production
it's very similar not entirely it's not
a not a perfect parallel but very
similar to the marquee titles that a
publisher will select they'll hand pick
a few
that they'll kind of double down on in
terms of of betting their bandwidth and
capital
to back very very similar did you find
by the way i'm just curious after the
success of the four hour work week and i
think it's fair to say that that
launched your career sure i think that's
fair to say
did you get any kind of response from
any of the publishers that had
originally rejected you that wanted in
on your next book or anything like that
you know i did get a couple of letters
from publishers who rejected me not only
rejected me
but did so with no grace whatsoever i
mean really abrasively
rejected me and
i don't think i replied to any of them i
found them amusing
i found them very amusing because you
can say no
in many different ways and there were
people who said no but did it
taking just an extra sense or two
to
encourage me
even though it wasn't a fit for them
and it was really just an extra sentence
or two and a shift in tone just a few
different words and
that made a real world of difference for
instance there was an agent she may
still be an agent really really capable
agent named jillian manus
who did not take me on as a client
but gave me a lot of really good advice
and feedback and was very generous and
gracious
in how she interacted with me and a
bunch of her advice helped me in my
writing of the book even though i ended
up
working with an agent who i still work
with steve hanselman
and i have the utmost respect for her
and i think she is she is a better
player a more competent actor
in that field because of the way she
handled herself and she had no reason to
do it at the time i shouldn't say no
reason but i felt like it was her
default way of existing in the world
because i had nothing to offer her at
the time but
there were examples like that and then
there were the counter examples of
people who were just like who the hell
are you kid this is a dumb idea
goodbye
and it just struck me as so
[Music]
short-sighted
in a way even if your job is to say no
99 of the time which is certainly true
for venture capitalists as another
example i mean a lot of people say no 99
of the time
it strikes me as a very good investment
of time to decide in advance how you're
going to do that with some degree of
grace
so yeah absolutely i received letters
from some of them and
none of them were going to get a bite at
the apple before you know the publisher
who took
a calculated risk on that first book
for sure and they got a great deal as
they should have right i mean i was
after all i'd been punched in the face
and kicked in the nuts 30 times or
whatever it was so i didn't exactly have
a lot of leverage
but that's smart to be aware of because
a lot of people get very resentful about
rejection yeah but they don't look at it
in the context of
i have got no backstory here yet i can't
point to
my successes in this world yeah
totally
and and it goes both ways right like you
can be gracious in receiving no
yeah i think that's very important and
you know these days it's like i get
through various channels you know
hundreds of communications a day
and 90 plus percent of those
are asking for something
and it's not physically possible for me
and my team to even respond to all of
those but if we do it's usually a no
and it's usually a polite decline that's
how i phrase it with my team i'm like
please polite decline
and some people get extremely upset
and they do the equivalent of responding
rudely as the publishers did but they do
it from the perspective of the person
who's asking for something
they get very
morally outraged and offended and then
they burn the bridge i say no thank you
i can't do this right now or there's no
bandwidth or i'm heads down on projects
and they get really offended
and
they guarantee that i'm never going to
do something with them in the future by
responding in a very
overly sensitive brusque way right so
it's it's definitely a two-way street
like if you're going to try to do
anything in the world like you you need
to get used to people saying no to you
there's a lot more no's than yeses and
and you know
the question that that i have
is you know how does one construct that
emotional moat
around that part of your psyche that you
want to protect and you realize that
they don't know me
this you know this this what's going on
here has nothing to do with who i
actually am yeah you know but i think
establishing that moat is critical for
emotional survival otherwise
more kicks to the head totally and also
you know i've
now on the receiving end developed
tremendous
empathy and compassion for people on the
receiving end because in the beginning
you know i might ask someone for a book
blurb and they would
say no and i would i would be very upset
i wouldn't respond rudely i knew i think
i knew enough not to do that but
it would stick for a while and i would
be very upset and i'd be like why would
they say no like this is such an easy
ask and this and this and this and i can
come up with a laundry list of reasons
why they should have said yes
and now that i'm in the receiving seat
like it's it's physically impossible to
respond i mean it's like if i look at my
phone right now i've got 98 unread text
messages from close friends
and then i have another
like 253 unread text messages on
google voice and it just goes on and on
834 notifications on calendar i mean i
can't physically respond to this many
things and
it is entirely possible
that the vast majority of people or a
high percentage of people who say no to
you will say no because they just don't
have the bandwidth to figure it out
and
just because it's a it's not a fit for
them
which you should accept is valid if they
say it's not a good fit
doesn't mean it's a bad idea
it just means
that your shoes are too [ __ ] tight
it's not gonna fit on their feet or
whatever it's not the right fit
and
it's gonna take a while if you have a
novel idea and if you're unproven in a
particular area it's gonna take a while
to find cinderella with that glass
slipper
right it's just gonna take a while and
it doesn't matter if you've had a lot of
success in one area it doesn't
automatically copy and paste to the next
in in many respects you're gonna have to
start over
and you know i really
respect you for doing that not once but
multiple times you know sort of taking
your not necessarily leave but departing
from a well-trodden path that you know
very well where you have all the
connections and you understand all the
dynamics
to
explore an area
where you're inevitably going to face
more
no's and i hesitate to say rejection
because i don't view those as exactly
the same do what i mean like rejection
distinction well it's like rejection i
guess just has such a
negative connotation
whereas
no not right now no not for me
uh don't quite have the
stigma or the stickiness of
rejection rejection is just a for me at
least has such a
heavy
connotation
so i don't think about it that way
and
it's been a strange journey
and an interesting one let me ask you a
question with respect to fundraising
without giving out your personal contact
information because i think that'd be a
terrible terrible idea i've seen that
backfire before
where could people go
to
maybe learn more about the production or
consider
supporting what you're doing with
personality the lloyd price musical
well as of yet because it's too early i
mean tickets don't even go on sale till
september
so you know if somebody was interested
they could message me on linkedin okay
that's easy jeffrey matt off all right
we'll include that in the show notes as
well for people so you can you can
direct message
big jeffrey maddoff
on on linkedin
and uh great i mean if that works that's
easy i suggest people do it that way and
those who are motivated will figure it
out
yeah and if they have just a bag of cash
they want to drop off i can give us the
many convenient drop-off locations
[Laughter]
well let's let's talk for just a little
bit longer
in the process of doing homework i saw
somewhere that you've read everything by
raymond chandler i think that's how you
say the last name yes james elroy you
talk about michael lewis charles dickens
you've clearly read
a lot
aside from your own book
which just as a reminder is creative
career subtitle making living with your
ideas
which has i think an average of five
stars on amazon it's very well reviewed
what
have you given most as gifts to other
people
well you preempted the actual answer
which is my own yeah right right that's
that's why i preamp
god damn you
there are books that i have suggested to
people that's that's good enough you
know and so a book that was
really amazing to me
michael lewis
wrote well first of all i think
moneyball was specific
spectacular book yes and i'm trying to
get billy being on the podcast oh really
i am we'll see fingers crossed billy if
you're listening i'd love to have you on
i mean michael lewis is as a non-fiction
writer
is so good yeah mind-boggling and uh the
way that he's able to make things
understandable
without dumbing them down
he's just so good and i've read
everything he's written except his
latest book i haven't read that yet
about pandemic but i will
moneyball which was great which you know
i read moneyball and freakonomics back
to back and it was like that's a good
gumbo yeah it was like a case study
right but i love the undoing project
you know i know the story of the undoing
project but i haven't read the book
it's
brilliant i had read about 15 years ago
i read heuristics and biases by daniel
kahneman and amos taversky quick side
note i was a test subject
of danny kahneman's at princeton where i
i was a subject in some of his
experiments just as a quick side note
yeah anyway
please continue well you know they
created the field of behavioral
economics and green hall i was sitting
there in front of a computer looking at
things on a screen and hitting space bar
or whatever the indication was
yeah
wild
never never met them yeah they're
brilliant and the
thinking about thinking
and why we believe what we believe
i found so amazingly insightful
and useful and it i was just blown away
by it i just absolutely loved it
so the undoing project went into who
they were as people
and it just even enhanced even more
what their whole mission was in terms of
behavioral economics so i love that
but michael lewis's books i have
recommended tremendously
same with timothy wu
timothy wu i don't know the name so he
wrote the master switch he's a professor
at columbia university it's incredible
about dissemination of media
and uh the attention economy
i may have screwed up that name but it's
timothy wu wu and he's brilliant and i
kind of read him like i put together
freakonomics you know with heuristics
and biases with timothy wu
i put together
james gleek
and information
which is
god it's an amazing book
i love things that
make me look at things differently and
you know challenge
my own beliefs
in really interesting ways so those are
the kinds of things that i recommend i
read mostly
non-fiction
back when i was reading a lot of fiction
i loved raymond chandler raymond
chandler created the prototype philip
marlow the hard-boiled
detective who's got integrity and a ball
of rye in the deep desk drawer
and uh
his books i was always sorry that they
ended because they were so much fun to
spend time with those characters and i
really loved it
have you ever read motherless brooklyn i
saw the film i thought that edward
norton and team did did a really nice
job with that they did and you know i
thought it was really interesting and of
course the eccentricity of of having uh
detective with
dress
you know was just
kind of interesting yeah and i'm a
sucker for any of these you know movies
whether it's la confidential which is
one of the best ones right you know with
the fedoras you know and i i just i love
that genre you know the film noirish
kind of genre i just love it and james
elroy who i mentioned
who
like writes with a blowtorch you know
it's uh okay
please elaborate
his use of language has such velocity to
it and is so strong
and he wrote la confidential that was
based on one of his books yeah
and
the movie which i loved
was like
a disney version of the book
that's hard to imagine i know but if you
read the book which i'd highly recommend
by the same name yes yeah it's
it's wickedly rough
but but really good if you like that
genre
i love it
i am uh i'm looking for more fiction
i've really
been drawn to fiction recently having
been a non-fiction purist for decades
but
i can't remember who said this
so i don't know the attribution somebody
can figure this out but you know the
masks we wear tell us more about the
truth
than the the real faces we own or
something like that right like that the
masks often tell us so much and so i do
feel like fiction can convey deeper
truths sometimes as effectively or more
effectively than non-fiction
i've really been drawn to that craft
recently do you have any favorite
documentaries
or movies
oh god this you know as you know i love
film
so to name a film
is really tough i mean i recently
rewatched
for
the 19th dime i don't know to kill a
mockingbird
which i
loved and i had the
additional joy
of uh turning my kids on to it when they
were like 12
and watching it with them
and there are certain points in that
film
intense subject matter yeah but i've got
really smart kids yeah and and they they
loved it and i loved when i saw tears
welling up in their eyes
at the same point that it happened with
me when i watched the film
and it's just so beautiful
quick sidebar to that
so
i had done a film for eliza minnelli at
radio city and there was a big
party afterwards in the rainbow room
which is as glamorous as you know the
movies make it it's gorgeous space and
it's wonderful
gregory peck was sitting there and
i said to my wife margaret it's weird
since i said to my wife margaret as
opposed to my wife alice or my other
wife
i said to margaret my wife
you want to meet gregory pack this is in
1991
and she said uh i'd pass out i said come
on so we go over and
i shake hands with him and said i've
always wanted to shake atticus's hand
and atticus finch is the character that
he played and he said you know it's
interesting that you say that and he has
by the way one of the great voices of
all time
i was just speaking with alan pakula who
produced the movie and we were wondering
if that movie would be made today what
do you think
and i said i don't know
but
what a sorry statement about our culture
it would be if a film that was that
great
wouldn't have been made
and i said were you aware that you were
making something
that was
going to live on for generations and he
said you know i've made over 174 movies
never before
or never since
did i have the feeling that i had when i
was making that
and the very first scene he said you
know we shoot movies out of sequence and
i said i'm aware and he said
very first scene is actually the
courtroom scene although it happens
later in the movie
and i walk out on set and harper lee was
there
i don't know harper lee wrote it like
that she wrote to kill mockingbird
and when i walked out onto the set
she got up burst into tears and left
she came back about an hour and a half
later and i walked over to her
you know he was wearing a three-piece
linen suit which is what her father
always wore
and she said i'm sorry i was so
overwhelmed
by how you reminded me of my father
but there was one thing that was missing
and he said what was that
said he always had his pocket watch and
a watch fob
and then she hands him her father's
pocket watch wow which he put into his
pocket and she said whenever he was
giving a closing argument he would rub
his thumb over the face of the watch the
pocket watch
i said wow and he said and when i got
the academy award for best actor for
that film
as i was giving the speech
i had my right hand in my pocket
and was rubbing my thumb over the face
of the watch i said oh wow and then he
takes his hand out of his pocket
and says would you like to see the watch
and he hands it to me wow
and i thought man
wow that was to me like this somebody
seeing the sacred shroud of turin or
something i mean it was just amazing
really amazing but that's a film that
not only was the book great
the movie was great so i have to
interrupt for a second because this
reminds me of an experience that we had
where we were at some party a camera
where it was la or something like that
and
i
was a huge fan of jason statham's i
don't know if you remember this
and he walked right past us at this
event
and ended up whatever you know 100 yards
behind us in the middle of this throng
of this this crowd
and i think i mentioned something along
those lines and you're like well should
we go meet him and i was like i don't
know i don't know i don't know and you
just grabbed me and we marched right up
to him and said hello and he was
extremely friendly he was very very kind
and gracious also built like a brick
[ __ ] house i mean god is that guy well
well built
and uh funny enough you know i saw that
photo about a year ago and i was like
wow since i've lost my hair i'm kind of
converging on jason statham
have you always had that chutzpah to
walk up to people or was that developed
or how did that come to be
oh god yeah first of all i just love
when gentiles use words like hook stuff
[Laughter]
after you're telling me that your
ancestors came here in like the 16th
century or something like that
mine didn't they were kicked out of a
country but uh
you know i like to keep my my doors open
you know i i think
most people
don't mind you approaching them
if it's about something nice
so i had a short conversation with them
because i said you know my son is a huge
fan of your movies
and when i watch them with him said you
know you've got something going on i
mean you can act you've got chops you
can really act
and you say oh man thank you and we
talked for just a moment or so and then
i said would you mind if we got pictures
with you
yeah yeah so the sure way to make sure
that nothing happens
is do nothing
yeah so worst case scenario he says get
away from me kid you know
worst thing he does is he says no
yeah but we both ended up with picture
that we really enjoyed and it was nice
to meet him because he was a very nice
guy yeah a really sweet guy and so it
was uh cool and i have seen his they're
married now i think
his wife i had shot many times
because she was a model and you know i
did some videos with her and she was
really really a nice person too
yeah i was supposed to have
jason and i think guy richie on the
podcast some time ago and then without
any explanation we were all slated to go
and then the phalanx of
god knows what in between
very last minute canceled so maybe
someday i'll get to actually thank him
in person for being so cool on our first
encounter
here's a question that might be a dead
end and i accept that possibility and
i'll i'll take the blame if that's where
it goes but
nonetheless i will ask good preamble
though thank you thank you i specialize
in preambles
if you could have a gigantic billboard
anywhere metaphorically speaking right
this is to get a message a quote
an image anything out to billions of
people what might you put on
that billboard doesn't have to be an
original could be from somebody else
whatever you want something
non-commercial
well if it was
an actual billboard
i would say
pay attention to the road
[Music]
that's a it's a very be jeffrey madoff
answer
and if it was a metaphorical in terms of
just
a metaphorical idea that i wanted you
know people to get would be
stay curious keep learning
stay curious keep learning i think
you've done an excellent job of that so
you walk the walk well you're very kind
it's true it's true i've seen it over
and over again that's very inspiring
and
but it's fun i mean that's you know when
you and i first met
all those years ago
the conversation which was going to be
you had a half hour i think and then we
were like four and a half hours later
yeah i remember because we were
ricocheting all over the place like that
i mean
it's a very enjoyable thing to do when
you're talking with somebody who i don't
want to presume you respect me but you
know i do respect you
but you know the same it's like it's
it's fun and you also unearth things
about oneself that
you might not have hit on otherwise or
you see it in a different way and i
think
that's a great thing about doing a
podcast isn't it when you
get to talk to people that you find
interesting and i don't know all of that
totally in some ways all the more so
when i know someone
and have the excuse and the pretext to
do all this creepy due diligence
that would otherwise be really strange
and
you know i think this is a pretty good
place to start to wrap up jeff are there
any other things you would like to
mention any
requests you have the audience anything
you'd like to say closing comments
anything at all
that you would like to add before we
bring this first conversation to a close
well i am going to be taking in a leap
into the podcast world
because of all the guests that i've had
in my class
you know i think that
you being a master of that and i've been
you know learning
in
and so i'm looking forward to that
because it's just you know i think like
you i think it's accurate to say
it's about spreading ideas yeah and
that's what's fun you know to do that
engaging with people about ideas i am
proud of my book
i i think that that was an interesting
thing especially as i was going through
some of the same things i was writing
about
you know in terms of that was one of the
things i was thinking about well was i a
failure
and all that and you know writing a book
about things you've experienced in life
can be therapeutic at the same time
and bring things up that maybe you know
i wouldn't have thought about
otherwise
and as i had already mentioned about the
teaching
is that
teaching
is such a great way to learn is such a
great platform to engage with ideas and
i've got
an audience that changes every semester
i really enjoy it and am very grateful
for an opportunity like this where you
know we can just
pinball back and forth and talk about
the kinds of things that interest us and
in scratching our own itches
we hope that we also do the same for our
audience
yeah well i'm excited for you to get
into the podcast game you're a natural
and you're already
doing the heavy lifting and you're doing
the interviewing you know how to do it
you are an expert storyteller and it's
just a matter of sharing the audio so i
think you'll do very well
and to
just repeat where people can find you or
a few different options
acreativecareer.com
that is at a creative career on
instagram the book is creative careers
subtitle making a living with your ideas
check it out you can also find madoff
not made off madoffproductions.com
which can be found at madoff productions
on instagram if you are interested in
learning more about possibly supporting
personality
subtitle the lloyd price musical which
i'm very very excited to see you can
direct message b jeffrey madoff
m-a-d-o-f-f on linkedin
is there anything
else anywhere else that people can find
you or any other links or any such
things that we should mention
well hopefully they'll look that well
actually they'll be hearing that podcast
this is kind of surreal self another m.c
escher thing i was going to say you
could tell them about this podcast but
the only way that they would hear it
it's like i had a teacher that would say
and if you're not here today please
raise your hand what
what
[Laughter]
so
no i think it's uh yeah
some people can't nothing else yeah
people can search your name and podcast
and by by the time this is reaching
their ears
perhaps they can find it and also
if it is live i will link to it in the
show notes
along with everything we've talked about
all the books all the people
all of the everything at tim. blog
forward slash podcast as per usual
and uh what fun be jeffrey madoff thank
you so much for making the time and
putting up with this
sauna
infused with hard kombucha it's been a
lot of fun i loved it and thank you very
much for having me on i really
appreciate it absolutely and
until next time to everyone out there
listening thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email where i
share the coolest things i've found or
that i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include favorite articles
that i've read and that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn i've been using expressvpn
all the time constantly since the summer
of 2019
and i find it to be a super reliable way
to make sure that my data are secure and
encrypted without slowing down
my internet speed whatsoever you don't
even notice that it's on it's one of the
best vpns on the market and it couldn't
be easier to set up their flow their
signup flow is actually incredible and i
encourage everyone just to check that
out all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would you click one
button in the expressvpn app to secure
100
of your network data one of the many
reasons
i use avpn is that free to access sites
all sorts of sites that you use every
day make their money by tracking your
searches
for video history and effectively
everything you click on and then they
sell this valuable data onto others when
you use expressvpn you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your ip
address that makes your activity more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your data to protect you from hackers
and assorted bad guys on the internet so
if you're on hotel wi-fi or public wi-fi
coffee shop wifi whatever this is what i
use so it's finally time to take back
your online privacy at expressvpn.com
tim by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free again that's expressvpn
tim one more time
expressvpn.com tim to protect your data
today
this episode is brought to you by public
goods the one-stop shop for sustainable
high quality everyday essentials made
from clean ingredients at an affordable
price i love these guys they have
everything from coffee to toilet paper
public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer
and they have everything from a to z
people on my team already used public
goods before they became a sponsor and i
tested them and now so do i one person
loves their ramen noodles for instance
for backpacking camping festivals like
burning man and so on another loves
their bamboo toothbrushes and now uses
them and many other products but uses
them more than his electric toothbrush i
love their candles and many of their
food staples my dog molly loves their
freeze-dried duck nibs the branding is
simple
nice optimized for calm instead of flash
and public goods searches the globe to
find healthy eco-friendly and innovative
products and then packages them using a
single streamlined aesthetic for your
home so you can get all of your premium
essentials in one place affordably and
avoid buying from a bunch of mismatched
single product brands public goods also
ethically sources and obsessively
develops each of their products to be
free of unhealthy ingredients and
harmful additives still very common on
drug and grocery store shelves they use
a membership model to keep their costs
low and pass on even more savings to
their customers best of all you can now
make your first purchase with no
obligation and i'll get to that in a
second small changes in the way we shop
the way you shop the way i shop can make
a big impact on personal health and the
world at large so join hundreds of
thousands of others who have switched to
their new everything store public goods
i worked out an exclusive deal just for
you my listeners you can receive 20
off of the products in your first public
goods order with no minimum purchase so
it's totally risk-free just go to
publicgoods.com
tim or use code tim that's tim at
checkout one more time that's
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com forward slash tim to receive 20
off of your first order
[Applause]
you